وعدا قبل المؤتمر الصحفي مع نظيره الروسي
برساله مهمه للغايه بالنسبه للعالم اجمع
وبالنسبه للدول الافريقيه الناميه على وجه
الخصوص فرفع سقف التوقعات لكن الرساله
كانت عن امال مستقبليه قابله للتحقيق
نعتقد انه يمكن التوصل الى حل بشان احياء
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود وذلك
بسد الفجوات المتبقيه وفي هذا السياق نجهز
مجموعه جديده من المقترحات بالتشاور مع
منظمه الامم المتحده واعلم انه يمكن
التوصل الى نتائج من خلال هذه العمليه
الجديده
ارد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين كان
ايجابيا من حيث الشكل لكنه ربط مساله
احياء اتفاق تصدير الحبوب بشروط يراها
بوتين ضروري للغايه
سنكون مستعدين للنظر في امكانيه احياء
الاتفاق حول الحبوب اليوم اخبرت السيد
الرئيس اردوغان رئيس تركيا بهذا الامر مره
اخرى وسنفعل ذلك بمجرد الاتفاق على رفع
القيود المفروضه على تصدير المنتجات
الزراعيه الروسيه
في يوليو تموز الماضي قررت روسيا عدم
تجديد الاتفاق الذي تم التوصل اليه قبل
عام في اسطنبول تحت رعايه تركيا والامم
المتحده نص الاتفاق على ان السفن التي
تنقل الحبوب الاوكرانيه يمكنها مغادره
الموانئ في منطقه اوديسا دون الخشيه من اي
هجوم روسي الى ان وضعت موسكو حدا للاتفاق
متهمه للغرب بعدم احترام جزءا من
الاتفاقيه التي تنص على تامين تصدير
المواد الغذائيه والاسمده الروسيه